People have been having sex and writing songs
about it and carving statues of it and changing
fashion for it since the dawn of humanity,
but it wasn't until fairly recently in the
1940s that serious Western scientific study
of sex began.
And by most accounts you can thank one guy
for that: Alfred Kinsey.
Kinsey was born in 1894 in New Jersey, to
poor strict Methodist parents.
He studied etymology in college, graduated
with degrees in biology and psychology before
heading to Harvard.
His doctoral thesis was on the genealogy of
Gall wasps, a subject he tackled with intensity;
meticulously collecting over five million
samples, measuring hundreds of thousands of
specimens.
And wasps are interesting and everything,
but Kinsey's interests drifted toward human
sexuality and his research in Indiana University
paved the way for decades of study into sex.
He surveyed thousands of men and women about
their sexual habits and histories, and found
all sorts of interesting things related to
sexual preferences, masturbation, orgasms,
and pre-marital sex.
He established the "Kinsey scale" indicating
degrees of sexual orientation) and went on
to write the seminal texts on sexual behavior
in the human male and female respectively.
Like many researchers of human behavior, Kinsey
and his colleagues were - and in some ways
still are - pretty controversial.
But he definitely succeeded in two very important
tasks.
One: he was an early adopter of a scientific
approach to studying sex, and two: he showed
that the popular perception of what people
do and don't do sexually, versus what people
actually do and feel, was often very different.
Since then we've seen innumerable sex-related
studies examining the physiological and psychological
and social elements of sex.
And, there's a whole lot of lingering misinformation
and judging morality swirling around the subject
of sex.
It can be a tricky topic for sure but we are
here to clear some things up.
It's the entire purpose of life so there's
no reason to blush.
So.
Sex.
That one little word has complicated so many
lives.
The desire for or lack of sex has spawned
poetry and made babies and transmitted diseases
and cost money and driven people batty and
kept late-night cable in business.
Even the word itself can mean many different
things.
First we've got the verb kind of sex, the
physical process of engaging in sexual acts
and intercourse, which, probably I don't need
to describe to you.
Then we've got the biological definition,
having to do with the anatomical parts that
go with the designations of male or female
or intersex - those who were born with the
reproductive parts that don't fall into the
predominant definitions of male or female.
And these are quite separate from gender,
or an individual's sense of identifying as
male or female or another gender identity
regardless of how that corresponds with their
actual reproductive plumbing.
For transgender people, for instance, gender
identity typically doesn't match biological
sex.
And remember that gender identity is completely
different from sexual orientation, which we'll
talk about in a minute.
So beyond definitions, we have the physiological
and psychological aspects of sex.
Let's start with the physiological, and with
that, Masters and Johnson.
In the late 1950's and 60's, American gynecologists
Williams Masters, and his collaborator and
future wife, sexologist Virginia Johnson,
did something no researchers had ever done
before.
They invited nearly 700 male and female volunteers,
many of them sex workers, to come into their
lab and get it on, either alone or with their
partners.
Their aim?
To record the body's physiological response
to sex.
This involved wearing a whole lot of wires
and heart monitors and such, and is probably
about as sexy as it sounds.
All the volunteers had to be willing and able
to show arousal and be capable of orgasm.
And over the years, Masters and Johnson recorded
more than ten thousand "sexual cycles".
The main thing they documented was that a
complete sexual response cycle involved four
distinct stages - excitement, plateau, orgasm,
and resolution - which Masters and Johnson
maintained happened in a linear way, one after
the other.
In the excitement phase, things are gettin'
goin', blood is rushing to all the necessary
places, genital areas are becoming engorged
and secreting lubricant.
Next comes the plateau phase.
Pulse, blood pressure, and breathing rates
keep increasing and genitals are becoming
fully engorged.
The penis is often secreting pre-ejaculate
as vaginal secretions increase until the big
event orgasm during which muscles all over
the body contract and breathing and pulse
rates hit their peak.
Of course, a biological male orgasm typically
releases sperm that may lead to fertilization,
depending on the situation, but female arousal
and orgasm also help facilitate conception,
again depending on the situation as those
muscle contractions and lubrication help draw
up and retain sperm in the uterus.
Finally, the body comes back down to its normal
state of affairs during the resolution phase.
It's during this phase that biosex males enter
a refractory period during which they're unable
to orgasm again for a few minutes to a day
or more whereas biological females refractory
period is very short in comparison.
While the four stage model of sexual response
is still taught today, some have criticized
both its rigid linear setup, arguing that
things don't always work so tidily in the
bedroom, and it's insistence in including
orgasm which doesn't happen for everyone all
the time.
Others also question the model's clinical
focus on only physiological factors arguing
the cultural attitudes, psychological and
relationship factors, and other external details
should also be considered when looking at
sexual response.
I'll get back to that in a minute, but before
we move on to the psychology of sex, we got
to talk about hormones.
You remember hormones, those chemical messengers
brewed up by the endocrine system that travel
through the bloodstream and regulate all sorts
of physiological and behavioral activities
from growth to digestion to sleep to sex.
Our sex hormones serve two major purposes.
One, they direct the physical development
of biological sex characteristics, and two,
they help activate sexual behavior.
Estrogens like estradiol contribute to female
sex characteristics and are secreted in greater
amounts by females than males and while all
humans make testosterone, it's the predominate
sex hormone for males, stimulating the growth
and development of male sex characteristics.
Now most female mammals become sexually receptive
when their estrogens peak during ovulation,
but it doesn't really work that way for humans.
Our hormones are more loosely related to sexual
behavior, although studies have found that
in general female's sexual desire spikes slightly
around ovulation, when woman are most fertile
and males can also be affected by this spike,
responding with higher levels of testosterone
when ovulating women are around.
But these short term changes hardly compare
to the larger more major hormonal shifts that
occur throughout a life time.
Puberty, for one, tends to get everyone a
lot more hot and bothered and interested in
dating and gazing at posters of their favorite
celebrity crushes and later in life, as sex
hormone production normally decreases, our
amorous urges and endeavors tend to decrease
as well.
Age affects our libido.
But in the end you might think of sex hormones
as fuel for your sexual engine, and while
an engine can't run on a totally empty tank,
it also won't run any better or worse on a
full tank versus a half tank.
We need our sex hormones, but we also need
the right psychological stimuli to turn us
on and keep us going sexually.
So, finally, let's look at some of these psychological
aspects of sex.
First, there are the very important social
and cultural influences.
Things like your families, your societies,
your religions, and your personal values.
Does your community view sex merely as the
means for reproduction or can it be fun too?
What are the views on premarital sex, and
homosexuality, showing some skin or kissing
in public?
Then there are the influences of external
stimuli.
In western society, we're constantly bombarded
with sexually charged content from movies
and TV to advertisements, R&B slow jams, and
Victoria Secret catalogs.
And constantly looking at images of things
that you find extremely attractive can lead
to folks viewing more average people, even
their own partners, as being less attractive.
But our sexual desire is also fueled by internal
stimuli.
Our imagination and memories and fantasies.
According to plenty of studies, at least 95%
of people fantasize about sex at some point.
The thing you need to keep in mind is that
none of these factors work independently of
each other.
How we respond to both external and internal
stimuli can be really heavily influenced by
social and cultural factors, and that is where
a lot of the thinking and studying of sex
has gotten really complicated.
Human judgment and morality is often entangled
with sex and desire and sadly, a lot of people
have been made to feel miserable for liking
certain things or being attracted to certain
people.
There's also just been a lot of misinformation
out there.
For ages, a lot of folks believed that masturbation
could make you go blind, become mentally ill,
or kill the neighborhood kittens.
It doesn't do that.
And as I know, you're thinking right now one
area of sexuality has been needlessly associated
with conflict, fear, and shame in many cultures
is sexual orientation.
For our purposes, sexual orientation can be
defined as a relatively enduring physical
or romantic attraction to another person.
Heterosexual, homosexual, and bisexual are
all types of sexual orientation.
And although the field once stigmatized non-heterosexual
orientations, we now know that homosexuality
and bisexuality are in no way related to mental
health.
Psychologists are also beginning to look more
in depth at other sexual orientations.
For instance, Asexuality or nonsexuality,
where no sexual attraction of any kind is
experienced.
In any case, whether a culture itself is friendly
to or tyrannical against any of these orientations,
all types prevail.
Sexual orientation is neither chosen nor changed.
So, what might cause these differences?
Hopefully you already know this but it's worth
repeating.
There's no evidence that sexual orientation
is determined by things like dominating mother
or passive father or sex hormone levels in
your adult body or your history of childhood
abuse or whether your parents were gay or
straight.
In other words, decades of research have led
most researchers to believed that once you're
born, there are no clear environmental factors
that influence your sexual orientation.
And there's been a lot of research into possible
biological components of sexual orientation,
like genetics, brain anatomy, prenatal conditions,
or other things.
It's also important to know that we're far
from understanding sexual orientation on a
purely biological level.
If anything, the evidence we've got simply
strengthens the idea that sexual orientation
isn't choice, but rather a naturally varying
occurrence among human beings, like height.
So.
After all this talk about sex, perhaps you're
wondering why we do it at all.
I mean, it feels good obviously.
But the biggest function of sex goes beyond
pure pleasure.
In fact, sexual intimacy serves many of life's
most basic purposes: some times procreation,
but also stress reduction, maintaining healthy
relationships, social bonding, and the expression
of love, and overall fulfillment.
People say he brain is the most significant
sex organ for a reason.
And intimacy is often its own reward.
Today, you learned about Alfred Kinsey's ground
breaking sex surveys, the differences between
how we define biological sex and gender identity,
and about Masters and Johnson's four-part
sexual response cycle.
We also looked at the role of sex hormones,
in our development and drive, how psychological
and social factors play into sex, how we think
about sexual orientation and why we have sex
in the first place.
Thanks for watching, especially to our Subbable
subscribers who make crash course possible.
To find out how you can become a supporter,
just go to subbable.com/crashcourse.
This episode was written by Kathleen Yale,
edited by Blake de Pastino, and our consultant
is Dr. Ranjit Bhagwat.
Our director and editor is Nicholas Jenkins,
our sound designer is Michael Aranda, and
the graphics team is Thought Cafe.